help could be on the way for america's
wild horse herds nevada congresswoman
dina titus plans to ban the use of
helicopters during often brutal
round-ups of the mustangs eight news now
chief i-team reporter george knapp is
here with his exclusive story the niece
and brian we've all seen these videos of
herds of wild mustangs running in terror
as blm contractors swoop out of the sky
stampeding the frightened animals across
rough terrain horrific injuries and
deaths of horses are now the norm they
happen pretty much every time there's a
roundup it's admittedly hard to watch
images like this one from a recent
operation at nevada's pancake complex
our i-team colleague vanessa murphy
reported about this young horse running
for its life despite an obviously broken
leg that animal and others had to be put
down and your money pays for all of this
since 2011 blm has forked over 36
million dollars to a handful of private
contractors to carry out roundups in
nevada and other western states it cost
more than 500 dollars per horse to
capture them congresswoman dina titus
saw the same video you just saw and
decided enough was enough
tomorrow morning she'll introduce
legislation to ban the use of
helicopters in wild horse roundups
but the roundups with helicopters are
the worst you saw the pictures from the
most recent one at the pancake area near
ely where they chased that little cult
tilly just ran down and then they had to
shoot them what purpose does that serve
so we need to find another method and
the first thing we can do is get rid of
outlaw ban those helicopters
a century ago there were more than two
million wild horses in america today
there are about seventy thousand more
than half of them here in nevada but
that's still too many according to blm
which plans to gather more of them this
year than ever before representative
titus says she'll introduce her bill
tomorrow morning and she expects to
garner bipartisan support you know
barring the use of helicopters would
mean blm would have to use methods that
don't create the same kind of stark
terror among the mustangs titus says her
slogan for this proposal is to quote
save a horse hire a cowboy we'll have
more on that proposal tomorrow evening